trade is flowing through the suez canal
again engineers have finally managed to
free the huge container ship blocking
the vital waterway
tugboats pulled the vessel off of a sand
bank allowing it to re-float
it halted traffic in both directions for
nearly a week
10 percent of global trade passes
through the canal in egypt
every day just look at it go
after bringing one of the world's most
important waterways to a standstill
the 400 meter long ship is moving along
at 1.5 knots
the salvage team did an excellent job uh
you know we were in a real critical
situation when it was touching
on both banks and there was real risk of
cracking in the center of the ship but
the game entirely changed once they got
that stern free
and were able to pivot it uh pivot it
back
parallel to the canal
pressure on rescue workers had been
mounting as the maritime traffic jam
grew to over 400 ships
suppliers had to decide whether to wait
indefinitely or sail an additional
seven thousand kilometers around the
african continent
for now they can breathe a sigh of
relief but questions remain
well i think this probably goes to show
is the fragility perhaps
of the global supply chain i mean this
is a
very significant maritime artery one of
only two major
canals in the world that you know
operate in this way in terms of moving
ships from one ocean to another
and so i think any blockage there has
proven
to be you know really really challenging
the ever givens technical managers said
initial reports ruled out any mechanical
or engine failure
as a cause of the accident but human or
other technical errors could still be
uncovered in the investigation to follow
and let's get more we are joined now by
bill cavanaugh who is a ship captain
and knows the suez canal well having
passed through it on a number of
occasions he joins us from cork in
ireland
uh welcome to the program and thank you
for being here uh
nearly a week we have heard to free this
vessel
what do you make of that it's
taken a week fantastic work by the
service crews and indeed a master and
crew on board the ship itself
it's been very difficult it's
unprecedented it has never happened to
this extent before there have been about
75 uh incidents in the past decade not
so that's a pretty good safety record
what has happened here is that the
bulbas bow has become stuck on the east
side of the channel
uh the bulbous bow um is a is a
protruding bow which
increases efficiency and speed for these
vessels for all large vessels
and because of this shape it actually
got embedded on the east side so they
were able to get to stern off first
and that enabled them to transfer some
ballasts or take in ballast into stern
which lifted the bow off a little bit
but
it took a long time because of that
bubba's bow becoming embedded
how difficult is it to navigate the
canal
isn't difficult at all actually um
except it's busy because they work in
convoys so
ships don't normally operate in convoys
except perhaps
in ice areas where they work in ice
convoys very rare
so the the most difficult part is
working within a convoy however it isn't
difficult because the
courses are more or less north south
they uh
wait in the great bitter lake for the
other convoy to arrive rather like a
siding in a railway
station and it's quite straightforward
actually but nevertheless the canal
itself is very featureless so that would
be very much dependent on
radar and um uh satellite navigation
systems
there's so many open questions as to why
this happened meantime you know on the
ground
we know many ships were stuck for days
because of this
how would that have been you think for
the crews on board for example
well it's very stressful for crews
because in the middle of this pandemic
crews are actually spending
more than their contract time on border
ship and this has become very stressful
for them
some crews are spending up to one year
on board their ships
they cannot get home many countries will
not allow them to come home
we're not allowed to pass through the
airports without quarantining
they're missing their families they're
missing their children and it's very
stressful for them so any kind of delay
like this would be
an additional stress for crews any
proactive measures that you can think of
or perhaps recommend that uh
you think might prevent something like
this from happening again
it's almost impossible to prevent human
error or errors like this happening but
we can mitigate or reduce the
possibility of those errors happening
again
and there are a few things that could
happen from the initial information we
have for example
there should be a maximum speed for
vessels transiting the canal
these types of ships uh this vessel was
doing 13 knots at the time of the
incident
and one would argue that perhaps seven
knots would be fast enough for
a 200 000 ton ship the connection of
tugs to the bow and stern at all times
for mega ships would also
mitigate um any incident like this
because if they did veer off course
suddenly
at least the tug would be able to um
hold their
own course to a certain extent and of
course
there is going to be a need to rewrite
the standard operating procedures for
the suez canal because they're going to
need
a better contingency planning in place
just in case something like this happens
again in other words what if
captain bill kavanagh in cork ireland
thank you
thank you